so our next speaker i've actually known
him for
like a decade or something it's been a
very long time right um but when he's
not coding in r and stan and i'm sure
other languages but particularly stan
he's a big fan of stan um he's djing
underneath and i've never i've seen his
name before his his dj name i've never
understood it because the way he spelled
it elite speak
but pronounce it it's cyclic
like a cyclic process all right i
thought it was cooler than you guys do
all right cool everyone please welcome
daniel
um
everyone else started with a joke and i
won't because that'll slow us down to
get to happy hour
oh yeah and i forgot i didn't include
this slide i this is a new talk it got
finished like back there a couple
minutes ago
um who am i
i don't know i've won a couple
hackathons now i've competed in three
and the third one i won a prize there
too so i've won a couple hackathons
that's why i'm talking about
how to win a hackathon
i've helped develop stan
the open source statistical
probabilistic programming language i do
code in r python c plus stan a bunch of
other stuff
all right so um
here's the one that i won in march 2022
a few months ago is the mit sloan sports
analyst conference hackathon it was
presented by espn and nhl
it was thursday 9 am to 4 pm that was it
that was the extent of the hackathon and
then they had the finals on saturday at
8 30 a.m
why 8 30 on a saturday i don't know
very little guidance they didn't tell us
what we were supposed to do they just
said here go do something
all the judges were experts in hockey
which i am not an expert in hockey this
is a new sport for me
what they gave us was nhl data and it
was tracking for
the 2020
stanley cup finals so six games of the
stanley cup finals they gave us tracking
data x y and z positions
for all 40 players there are only six
players on the team
at a time on the ice we have 40 because
you get to see the bench
the puck the referees at about 100 hertz
and by the way this is not time aligned
to the game time this is absolute time
and so you have to figure out what time
this happened
we have play-by-play data so we had two
streams of play-by-play
official scores data so they'll come in
and say that was a goal it happened at
1202 and they'll mark it down and say
who did it who the sys came from and
they also had automatically generated
data they had other data like rank
dimensions player info we knew height
weight
age where they were born their parents
names i think some random stuff
and um
this is kind of fun talk because
our project won this is going to be a
talk within the talk i'm going to give
you a very short version of my talk
and then we'll get into like how you can
actually win hackathons
so here we go
so this is a sloan glo
sloan goalie card
and what we focused on was um
first of all the meta problem is that
the valuation hockey is too result
driven
in nhl hockey tracking data there was
only one winner of the full 2020 stanley
cup finals and that was a tampa bay
lightning
so that's not enough to do anything with
there are only six games
and they're only 33 total goals scored
so what we wanted to do is we want to
turn that into something that's process
driven so what leads to this win
so we looked at the process we found
that
people take shot attempts there over
over 500 shot attempts on the 33 goal
scored you can see i used r for the
graphics
sorry there's more background that you
can't see but that's okay
so we framed this into a problem does
goal tender depth matter so that's the
distance that the goalie is from the
from the center of the net
and why do we look at this the first
reason is that it turns out nhl goalie
depth data is not public so no one's
really seen this outside of nhl analysts
um
is a goalie more or less conservative
conservative meaning if you're further
out you're aggressive if you're further
back you're defensive
and
fans all of us might have a sense of
where a goalie stands but we can't
quantify it so we don't know
does the depth of play change shot
percentage
that should be an obvious question that
we'd want to know if we can change
something about a goalie's plan and this
is all part of the process
so what we did was we modeled shot
percentage with goalie depth included
since this is a new covariate that we
hadn't seen
i wrote a bayesian logistic regression
in stan
um
and it had the distance and depth
properties in it
and what the output of this model said
was that there is a difference between
the two goalies um and you can get kind
of see it from the the heat map here
i'll skip through this this slide for a
little bit because this talks about the
exact goalie differences
um but it did lead to how should we
improve the model where can we do that
should each goalie play differently
that's the ultimate question we want to
get to
what we did in that time was we built an
actual web app which i won't pull up
right now i have more slides later
and then thank yous
it was a team i found a teammate we did
this all in a day
and now i get to talk about the strategy
for winning
a hackathon
so it's pretty simple the way i see it
there are four steps you define a
problem you specify a solution
you implement the solution and then you
build some sort of interactivity into it
i'll get into that just a little bit all
right
so we got time all right so the first
thing you want to do is actually define
the problem
this is really important you want to
understand why it matters and to whom
you want to understand what game you're
playing so each hackathon is different
you want to get in there you want to
understand who's judging it why are they
judging it what are they looking for if
you can't find a problem that they
understand
it doesn't matter what you do you're not
going to win
and then you want to communicate this to
people and you want them to believe that
it's a problem that you should look at
if you do that just that don't even come
up with any solution you'll be in the
top third i guarantee it don't need to
do any coding nothing
um spend the whole time just to find
this problem
so in the slides that i have this is the
slide that that kind of spoke to the
judges does gold tender death matter i
pulled up some information from that was
from the nhl like goalie training manual
and you know they they
the people were telling me that there is
a difference in play now from 20 years
ago they do think it matters
and we identified that they don't have
data for this
the second step is to specify a solution
we're not talking about any
implementation what we want to do is
describe a solution and understand
whether or not it solves the problem
and what you really want to do is
communicate to them that if you could
solve this problem in this way
they wish they had it
right like you do that much and in the
top 10 of any competition that you'll
get into that's it you don't have to do
any coding you could you could like
paint microsoft paint it and it'll be
okay
um for us this was this slide here where
i showed a stand model that actually
incorporated
both the distance of shots which people
have seen before but also the goalie
depth and so now i've painted them a
picture that we might have something
that uses the goalie depth to help us
predict how
what a shot percentage would be for an
offensive player
the third
is to implement the solution
and so this is
this is where you actually have to put
in work and you have to be
be really pragmatic
most people aren't able to make it this
far most people aren't able to deliver
anything of substance because they bite
off too much so you want to go and
narrow it down
be pragmatic about what you can build
and you want to remember that all this
is is a proof of concept
if it passes the smell test if a judge
goes and looks and says
i can kind of believe that maybe
that's it that's all you have to do
um
all right and the thing that you want to
focus on when you're communicating this
is focus on your accomplishments don't
tell them where it
where you could have done better they
don't care they don't know
to say what you did so for us we built
out this web app it had
uh two goalies you can actually flip
through the goalies
you can um go and look at each of the
shots play by play see what distance it
was and where the goalie was at that
time
and we did this we let them sit on that
and remember they don't know what you
could have built you have that in your
mind it doesn't matter you want to tell
them what you did build and how that
actually solves this the problem you do
this and you'll end up as a finalist i
i'm pretty sure you you've beat out
almost all the competition if not all
the last thing you can do
to really seal it is um build in some
interactivity
give the user something that they can do
something
if something with um
so the way i think about it is
counterfactuals but what if if they can
answer a what if question
off of what whatever you built then
you've done something beyond what they
expected you to do
so for us it was what if the goalie
actually stood a little further out
from the goal what if he was playing
closer in
what if you know and
you don't have to lay out everything you
want the judges to start going oh i can
answer this question that i'm interested
in
once you get there you're sold um
and so the the communication key here is
that
you want to provide um the potential
to provide insights you don't have to
provide it all to them you just want
them to believe that you possibly could
do it at least at the hackathon setting
great all right
and so now i'll talk a little bit about
the work
that you need to do
so if you're competing in a hackathon i
would suggest you come in with the tech
stack already decided
um
slacking slack for communication github
git for code um
uh i would use for me i used r shiny and
stan
a little less shiny for this project but
it was still there um my teammate used
python javascript to build the web app
and so we split that way
it doesn't quite matter which you choose
to choose something that you're
comfortable in and can do something
quick
please don't ignore devops if you've all
been ignoring devops think hard
you want continuous integration you want
deployment and you want testing
even from the start you should think
about this before you enter
that way when you do something
you see the results immediately and as
you're going through this you can
iterate very fast and you don't have to
worry about oh how do i get this in
front of somebody that should all be
settled before you enter
um
for picking teams it's it's tricky um
you can go farther with others
but it's definitely harder to line when
you have more people
so think hard if you enter these
competitions who your teammate is
um and you cannot you absolutely cannot
micromanage um you have to split
responsibilities
if one teammate says they're gonna do
one thing
and that's not you
you have to let it go even if it fails
you just can't do it
so this makes actually choosing
teammates very hard this is why you end
up
arguing about what the problem is what
the solution is and what how to
implement
and the the last thing i want to tell
you is to focus so focus on the problem
the solution the implementation the
interactivity
keep communicating remember to keep
communication to the judges in mind and
remember to play the game
and then keep everything else out
if someone wants to argue about agile
processes like wrong team like that's
not for a hackathon sorry
um
all right and so if you're thinking
about entering hackathons are hard and
they are stressful
they're they're very very high variance
game because rules differ to begin with
every hackathon i've seen has a
different set of rules different set of
judges different amount of time
this particular hackathon they let us
finish and do a preliminary result and
then go away for two days and then
present our final we didn't take
advantage of that time but
different rules
remember performance here doesn't
reflect your personal ability please
don't take this as like a measure of how
good or bad you are at any skill like
it's okay you can lose the hackathons
and be fine you can win at hackathons
and not be great you know that's
it's okay
take it as an opportunity to learn
how to work under pressure how to
communicate as fast as you possibly can
and to focus and often without any of
the other overhead of workflow tools
just like a piece of paper you slide
that back and forth
you have github issues just open close
done
finally this is my last slide thanks to
to everybody
my teammate fabrice
that that qr code is my linkedin if
anyone wants to connect with me
my family gave me a lot of support
always a stan team
jared nicole and the nyr conference team
you've been great thank you let's go to
happy hour
thank you very much